[Music]  Wes Anderson the quirky director of such  indie films is Rushmore on the Royal  Tenenbaums also made a Star Wars  audition tape I'm not sure he's the  right guy either but take a look  [Music]  let me be clear one solo you'll jump a  lot of money so I'm here to kill you  geez greed oh it's kind of a lot to  process can we get a drink first I mean  what do you do is there a waitress or  the order at the bar if you give me the  money that you owe I might forget that I  saw you you see what I got you know I'm  coming up short is there any way I can  do this in installments or that's not  how this works  Jabba doesn't have time wait a minute  are you reaching for your gum I'm afraid  I am you probably think I'm a real jerk  sorry about the mess kid  [Music]  [Applause]  he could be perfect yeah yeah I like it  absolutely perfect like it